[Music]
Kanye West Kim Kardashian the two of
them having a baby
everyone's going nuts well so far nobody
knows if the baby's a boy or a girl but
they could find out today during a
routine ultrasound let's go now live to
Kim Kardashian's exam room if you would
and there's the doctor he's examining
Kim Kardashian on the table and there is
the baby baby looks fine and healthy the
baby is just wait a minute realizing now
that she's Kim Kardashian and Kanye
West's child not happy about that and
making a break for it the baby is
baby is getting away of West Oakland
septa and making a break for it down
there's a home a they've got security
and the doctors are after the baby the
baby will not be taken the baby getting
back
down the staircase the baby does not own
a penny using the placenta to get into a
police car has hot-wired the police car
and is making a break for it this is big
news Kanye and Kim's baby moving down
the highway that looks to be the 405
maybe the 101 that is an incredible
story
incredible like that baby not happy
about those parents we will check back
in on him and keep you updated what's
going on you're kidding I'm told that
he's abandoned the cop car he is now
he's what I'm pretending to listen
he's hijacked shut up
what's that Jeff
he's hijacked a motorcycle and he's
headed this way that's insanity
[Applause]
[Music]
baby's fine baby took that corner a
little fast but now baby's fine and the
placenta safely in a sidecar and there
[Applause]
where do you think he what do you think
you got the little goggles I don't know
stupidest thing we've done in a long
time